[Music]
you know as Gwen Stefani has said it's
my life don't you forget okay I think we
have time for one more question
Yeah right there this questions for
Quinta Quinta you're such a strong woman
what is the moments that have
compromised your ideas of feminism and
how did you deal with that that one's on
me oh you want me to bring your great oh
no you know what I should know sneak
that wherever I want because you know no
should for anything in it because that's
feminism okay no no bring your dryer be
a mini Oh dancer turned rapper just like
car TV though okay I don't think she's
that bad no Caitlyn Jenner is a
beautiful woman she is so brave
[Music]
how about Gabrielle Union she's a good
role model right and Kylie Jenner okay
no Hillary would have been the answer I
can't believe we all voted for her and
she didn't win although for her love me
I voted for in the primaries of course
f51 right right I was emotion about
Hillary I'm just saying
Telstra's music video wasn't that bad
I'm just saying it wasn't a bad music
video Freddie
it wasn't bad I don't know how to put
this
while those women are all great if you
grow up to be like one of them I don't
know what I'll do and there's a chance I
might disown you
that's not very feminist that way I know
I'm working on it
mm well you know what I still think sex
in the city is a good show but I make up
for it by just listening to some Beyonce
[Applause]
his hands are legal weapons he will go
to prison but he finished my massage and
he was super strong as he used to be an
ex-boxer and I was a little scared but
that was our not to think about it
Quinta mm-hmm Quinta what are you
looking at him hello baby
it's not a baby it's a child and if he's
looking at me okay this game he's lying
Kate he's a liar
he's a kid don't be fooled
that's all Trump got elected now look at
us losing the DAC ABC what the actual
hell are you talking about he's making
his Dino nuggets evening I come
dinah'll ciao what's up all right I'm
gonna count to three and I want you to
turn around and catch him in the act one
going - I don't care - Quinta three look
Kate look look look oh he really is so
cute
oh he just winked at me that's it don't
worry about it what's up little man
what's up not so bad now that I'm here
are you excuse me can we can we help you
yes thank you for parenting dina Lohan
your son's a menace you too sir you're
not off the hook calm did he do
something uh he is making his Dino
nuggets eat me and he is looking at me
I'm sorry he's he's at a very playful
age he's a toddler do something do
something about it Jacob apologize to
the lady I'm sorry thank you that's all
I wanted all right you guys have a great
day
how do you play
because you're so sure are you gonna
learn today you're gonna learn
well where do you want to get wings now
buddy have you ever been to KFC
yeah I'm not an extraterrestrial okay
let's go there okay
hey the colonel what is he whispering
cuz you're not supposed to be on the
phone on the doctor's office no there's
a sign that says it s the office we'll
crash like a plane or something I mean
I'm doing okay I'm fine don't love you
too
well let's not talk about naming it
Michaels cute I don't like that no not
remain no other Jacksons what does the
through the Jackson's oh don't sweat it
it's a dumb rule it keeps the noise down
before we're all on our phones all the
time anyway I'm on tinder I don't have a
patient really you tinder you must clean
up on that bad boy huh dr. USC grid how
do you own do USC yeah actually they
have been bad lately dates been bad yeah
yeah I don't think I'm enough of a boy
Sam I wanna get a mental image of my
doctor saying boy that is good guess I'm
a little too old and dot reflow
I think you're too doctors for then yes
sir I got it all right well enough Tommy
you are not pregnant
Wow okay yeah you came in because of the
missed period yeah or the spotty one
rather well you're anemic oh yeah I
forgot about that
yeah you can't forget you gotta get your
iron in or everything go out of whack
including your period right all right
well be on top of it and why don't you
take a pregnancy test before coming in
there oh I did a shouty just wanted to
be sure got it
Emma oh we haven't protected sex with
the boyfriend I am we aren't okay I
think we're good
it's not baby time yeah awesome uh but
you might help me with my entailing
laughs really yeah
can use it okay sure I'm gonna charge
you double what you charge me though
that's my copay apply no all right you
know what maybe you want to take scuba
diving lover out of your bio because if
I saw that I'd actually report you you
know saved that from l3 you don't want
to interrupt with that that's something
you saved for the third act okay cool
call me millennial cuz I got nothing in
the oven
no yeah nice cool that's great and we
get to go to Vegas you weren't gonna
stop drinking with me
no Wow yeah I'm joking of course I would
have
where are you it sounds echoey oh the
Attic why I was just looking around
seeing if we could use the space as a
different room well that's something
yeah tonight what you just want to have
some wine and maybe go see a movie or we
could stay in whatever you want to do
yeah smoke some weed yes yes and plan
our Vegas trip we should get one of
those rooms that has the bar in it but
it's not a minibar it's just free yeah
okay
[Music]